this is a devops engineer they need to
find out why their application is
throwing errors in production they have
some alerts coming in and are hoping to
use duet AI in Google Cloud to help them
find the root cause and resolve it let's
observe this devops engineer as they use
duet AI to figure out what's gone wrong
and fix
it it all started with some helpful
emails alerting our engineer to an issue
with one of their Cloud projects while
useful as alerts these notifications are
not always very precise or informative
so some more digging will be needed
something is clearly wrong and today
we're going to get to the bottom of this
mystery faster with the help of AI they
go into the monitoring console to see
details on the incident and yes there
are errors showing up an intermittent
Spike but why to find out the true scope
they will look into the logs with a
Prometheus query but feeling Rusty they
ask duet AI to help using a natural
language explanation they can get a
query that gives a summary of all
services impacted by this error awesome
now they can see the full view of what
services are having problems due to this
error Spike next why is this happening
in the logs Explorer they detect an
illegal buffer error but then it's full
of references to code and multiple files
rather than go digging manually let's
use duet again explain this log entry
gives a new side panel with a handy
summary and a conversation opportunity
of course of course they want to fix the
problem ASAP so it's time for them to
ask duet AI in plain English for help
duet AI gives context definitions and
follow-up links laying out A playbook
for how to resolve this illegal buffer
issue and get the services into a happy
State once more our engineer has saved
hours of investigation and digging
thanks to duet AI so they can fix these
errors faster and now they have more
time to pursue their true passion
juggling what will you
[Music]
build